[Music]  hugh jackman knows a thing or two about  hosting the Oscars and has some sage  advice for this year's host Jimmy Kimmel  mis-advice I go with Steve Martin he  said first 45 minutes that's the best  audience of your life from that moment  on the room is filling up with people  who did not win so just hurry up and get  to the end he's funny and I'm not so  he's doing for this fun speaking of the  end  I'm not whatever it is you think I am on  March 3rd Hugh will hang up his claws as  Wolverine Logan will be his last x-men  movie I've known two cameos nine films  this is it it really hit me about a week  ago when I saw it for the first time  finish I shed a tear or five or many  more than people say there's a bit of  sweet there's nothing bitter about it  it's sweet I'm very grateful I'm on it  it's but it's you know there's a lot of  emotion around I'm very proud of the  film and a third thing we fought really  hard to make the film we felt was right  for the character